[Música]
hola soy natalia cabrera y esto es aqui
américa el espacio de france 24 para
revisar en profundidad las noticias e
historias de nuestro continente esto es
lo que veremos hoy desde mensajes en
redes sociales advirtiendo a los
bolivianos que si se vacunaban podían
convertirse en criaturas mitológicas
hasta la desconfianza en la medicina
tradicional frenaron el proceso de
inoculación en el país andino pero
gracias a los jóvenes ahora se aceleró
ya que han acudido masivamente a
vacunarse para ponerle fin a la pandemia
de la desinformación
y haití despidió al presidente joven el
mois con un funeral de estado que fue
costeado por la familia del mandatario
asesinado luego de que su viuda
rechazara que se emplee el dinero
público para sus funerales
entre tanto ariel ingrid asumió como
primer ministro en un aparente primer
paso hacia adelante en el país caribeño
y un dictador millennial el presidente
de el salvador nadie buque le anunció
que duplicará de 20.000 a 40.000 el
número de soldados del ejército según él
para luchar contra las pandillas pero la
oposición le preocupa que sea un
mecanismo para la represión y consolidar
su concentración de poder
llevamos de inmediato a bolivia para
nuestra historia principal el avance de
la vacunación contra el kobe 19 avanza
con lentitud por varios motivos no solo
por la demora en el acceso sino una vez
adquiridas por la desconfianza de los
mayores de 50 años sin embargo
recientemente se ha acelerado con los
jóvenes lo que eleva la esperanza para
conseguir la inmunidad colectiva veamos
el informe de nuestra corresponsal en la
paz mery vaca
la vacunación para prevenir el commit 19
se ha acelerado en bolivia gracias a que
jóvenes como edwin yupanqui de 21 años
se han volcado decididamente a los
puestos de inmunización con la primera
de las alumnas siempre hay que tener la
aplicación no detener y cuidar a los
familiares
deportes
pedro castillo de 24 años se vacunó por
razones similares a las de edwin pero
también por el fútbol para prevenir la
enfermedad que dar a mis familiares y
también para mi actividad diaria que nos
están pidiendo en las canchas grabadas
el carnet de vacunación bolivia comenzó
su plan de vacunación hace más de cinco
meses pero en los grupos mayores de 50 y
60 años sólo la mitad de las personas
previstas se han vacunado marinas rodas
es una enfermera jubilada de 80 años
pese a haber vacunado a miles de niños
en su vida ella ha decidido no hacerlo
contra el cubil 19 son vacunas
experimentales y escuchando noticias hay
algunas secuelas que queda entonces por
la edad que tengo no estoy segura de que
si me va a ser bien o me va a ser
marina a veces olvida usar barbijo pero
siempre lo lleva en la mano está segura
de que su fe católica evitará que
enferme
cerca del lugar encontramos al alcalde
de la paz iván arias quien cree que los
jóvenes son los que darán confianza a
sus padres las respuestas de los jóvenes
es increíble son ellos los que han
movido esto y han llevado a sus papás y
sus papás que estaban dubitativos han
sido más bien motivados la tercera ola
está en desescalada pero golpeó con
fuerza cuando el país se llegó a
registrar hasta 3000 casos diarios y
hasta 100 muertos cada jornada ahora las
autoridades esperan disminuir el impacto
de la cuarta ola con la vacunación de
los jóvenes
ariel ngog y tomó oficialmente las
riendas de haití tras jurar esta semana
como primer ministro en su primer
discurso a la nación caribeña hizo un
llamado por la unidad en la nación
sacudida por el asesinato del presidente
joven el movice el funeral del
mandatario se celebró este viernes en la
residencia privada de su familia luego
de que su viuda rechazara que se
utilizará el dinero del estado para su
sepelio con estos sucesos haití parecen
empezar a dar pasos hacia la estabilidad
que aunque data de mucho antes del
magnicidio se agudizó con el veamos más
en el informe de luís muñoz
las pandillas crecían en haití los
desplazados aumentaban y la violencia
detenía la ya históricamente estancada
economía haitiana un colapso que se
evidenció el 7 de julio de vance el
presidente joven el mois fue asesinado
por una unidad presuntamente formada por
26 colombianos y dos haitianos
estadounidenses y su mujer la primera
dama martín moix herida en el ataque
señaló como responsable a la oligarquía
a la que se enfrentaba a su marido
paralelamente a la investigación inició
una lucha de poder el primer ministro
interino claude joseph quien asumió el
liderazgo reivindicaba liderar el país
también lo reclamaba joseph lambert
presidente del senado y finalmente ariel
enric un neurocirujano designado primer
ministro en la semana de la muerte del
presidente joseph y lambert se retiraron
tras presiones diplomáticas y el martes
20 de julio ariel henrry tomaba posesión
con el respaldo de las naciones unidas y
la organización de estados americanos de
esta forma se desencalla va el relevo de
moix pero la crisis política continúa la
oposición reclama que ya debe
de haberse celebrado elecciones contando
la primera victoria del presidente moix
en 2015 que fue anulada para el difunto
jefe de estado su reelección en 2017 le
daba el poder hasta 2022
moix antes de su magnicidio ya había
convocado elecciones presidenciales y
legislativas para el próximo 26 de
septiembre comicios que el nuevo primer
ministro ariel en rey tendrá que
conseguir que se celebren de una vez por
todas
vamos a méxico para revisar otras
noticias de las américas esta semana
el estado de veracruz aprobó la
despenalización del aborto hasta la
semana 12 con este ya son 4 los estados
mexicanos los que permiten la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
entretanto el estado de méxico aprobó
que las personas trans puedan modificar
su acta de nacimiento para que refleje
su identidad
a nivel nacional pasó algo similar en
argentina que se convirtió en el primer
país de américa latina en reconocer las
identidades no binarias el gobierno de
alberto fernández hizo oficial un cambio
por el cual las personas no binarias
podrán identificarse con una equis en
lugar de femenino o masculino tanto en
su documento de identidad como en su
pasaporte
y el senado de chile aprobó el
matrimonio entre parejas del mismo sexo
con posibilidades de adopción tras
cambiar el concepto de madres o padres
por el de progenitores se trata de un
proyecto de ley que fue presentado en
2017 durante el segundo mandato de
michelle bachelet ahora el texto pasa a
la cámara de representantes donde se
espera que sea aprobado definitivamente
y seguimos en el salvador porque el
presidente nayib duque le anunció que el
ejército aumentara de 20.000 a 40.000
soldados según él con el fin de luchar
contra las pandillas sin embargo el
anuncio genera preocupación entre la
oposición que teme que las fuerzas
armadas sean utilizadas para reprimirlos
en medio de un clima de temor por la
concentración del poder que tiene el
mandatario millennial
un militar por cada pandillero ese es el
plan a 5 años del presidente del
salvador nadie bukele para combatir la
inseguridad porque tardaremos 5 años
porque no se puede duplicar la fuerza
armada tan rápido pero la ventaja es que
cada 15 semanas tendremos otros mil y
pico de elementos es decir no tendremos
que esperar 5 años para ver los
resultados las nuevas tropas se suman a
los 9 mil 825 soldados que ya trabajan
junto con la policía para contener a las
pandillas mara salvatrucha y barrio 18
que tienen unos 70 mil miembros 16.000
de ellos encarcelados en lo corrido de
2021 los homicidios disminuyeron en un
60% pero en 2020 el salvador registró un
promedio de 20 muertes por cada 100.000
habitantes pese a que las pandillas
flagelan a los salvadoreños con
homicidios y extorsiones a la oposición
le preocupa que este refuerzo de las
fuerzas armadas desencadene en represión
ya en febrero de 2020 bukele desafió al
entonces congreso opositor al ingresar
sin invitación a la sede
legislativo acompañado de soldados y
policías portando armas largas para
presionar la aprobación del presupuesto
para su plan de seguridad desde entonces
la comunidad internacional acusa al
mandatario salvadoreño de socavar las
instituciones del país y buscar
concentrar el poder pues en mayo el
nuevo congreso controlado por sus
aliados destituyó a los magistrados de
la corte suprema con el ejército la rama
judicial y la legislativo a su favor
bukele podría convertirse en el primer
dictador millennial y eeuu y canadá
están ardiendo en llamas una nube del
humo provocado por los incendios
forestales cruzó el continente y nubló a
ciudades de la costa este como nueva
york y washington pero porque la costa
occidental de norteamérica es más
propensa a incendiarse y qué papel juega
el cambio climático en que cada vez sean
peores las llamas les contamos en el
siguiente informe
más de 300 focos de incendios forestales
en british columbia y 80 más ardiendo en
la costa oeste de eeuu el humo del más
grande de ellos bautizado como but lak
fire en oregón es visible desde el
espacio para las autoridades la causa es
evidente
en la costa oeste y aquí en oregón la
crisis peligrosa del clima ha exacerbado
las condiciones en el terreno estamos
viendo sequías inmensas en todo el
estado olas de calor sin precedentes y
temporadas de incendios que están
llegando antes más rápido y duran mucho
más
washington el primer factor detrás del
empeoramiento de los incendios
forestales es de hecho el calor y el
clima seco causado por el cambio
climático la ola de calor récord de este
año ha consumido el paisaje más rápido
de lo usual las temperaturas extremas
también han llevado a que haya menos
nieve en las montañas para aliviar las
sequías y actuar como una barrera otro
factor clave las políticas contra
incendios hace varios siglos las
comunidades nativa
usaban incendios controlados para
contener la vegetación pero en los
últimos 100 años la mayoría de los
estados occidentales detienen a los
incendios espontáneos creando bosques
profundos y permitiendo que hojas secas
pinos y otras plantas se acumulen y con
esa abundancia de combustible sólo se
necesita una chispa y ahí entran los
relámpagos la causa principal de los
incendios naturales las llamas de la
canadiense british columbia han sido
atribuidos a varios rayos ligados a su
vez a la ola de calor pero la mayoría de
los incendios forestales en eeuu son
causados por actividad humana como el
can fire de california que en 2018 fue
encendido por una línea eléctrica
defectuosa o en septiembre de 2020
cuando una pareja en el sur de
california desató un incendio forestal
cuando usó fuegos artificiales para
revelar el sexo de su bebé
y me despido en perú mes y medio después
de las elecciones pedro castillo fue
confirmado como presidente por el jurado
nacional de elecciones keiko fujimori
reconoció su derrota luego de que las
autoridades desestimaron sus denuncias
de fraude el castillo tiene una semana
para organizar su gabinete y se reunió
esta semana en el palacio del gobierno
de lima con el actual presidente
interino francisco sagasti para iniciar
el proceso de traspaso de poder gracias
por acompañarme en esta emisión de aquí
a américa pueden ver más en france 24
punto com
[Música]